-Here's how it works.
In front of us are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One confession is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players have
60 seconds to interrogate you,
and then they have to guess
if you've been lying
or telling the truth.
Matthew will go first.
Tariq, which envelope
should Matthew open?
-I'm going to say --
The bottom, please.
-Number two.
-Yep. Number two.
-Number two says...
-Here we go.
-Ooh-hoy!
[ Laughter ]
I, McConaughey,
got charged by a mountain ram
at edge of the Grand Canyon
and had to throw
my 6-month-old child
15 feet through the air
to my wife to save him."
-Well, I don't know.
Now the grilling begins.
-Hurry up.
-What year was it?!
-This was my 40th birthday.
-Yeah, well, that's interesting.
16 months. Do the math there.
I don't know
how old your kid is.
But, uh, wait.
At the Grand Canyon.
Was the Airstream there?
-Yes, it was.
2004. The one in the picture
you just saw.
-So you threw the baby
to your wife?
-Yes. I threw --
-Who was --
-Who had scattered down
along the edge
when the ram had me here
with about a 20-foot drop.
-A ram.
-And I had to --
After I had already
got rid of the dog,
I had to launch Levi
through the air for my wife
to catch so we didn't
get rammed off the edge.
-So you saved the dog first?
-Well, the dog --
[ Laughter ]
It was like those masks
in the airplane.
-Okay. Okay.
-So, the dog was the one
that was pissing the ram off.
The dog's the one
that starts growling first.
So I'm like, "B.J., unh-unh."
I had to get rid of the dog.
-Was this like a baby ram,
or like a full-on...?
-No, this was the "alpha."
-Mm. Mm.
-Yeah.
I'll tell you how, in a minute,
I knew that.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-It's not a "Deliverance" story.
-I think he just --
I think you gave it away.
There's no -- It has to be true.
-What?! I say it's a lie.
[ Laughter ]
-Hee-hee-hee!
That's a good one, isn't it?
-Is it?
-You know what?
[ Laughing ]
That's 100% true.
-What?!
-I knew it. I knew it.
Really? You threw the baby?
-And here's what happened.
I mean, we were -- we were
having a picnic up there,
and then when I noticed --
And I back up to the edge
after I've gotten rid of the dog
and gotten rid of my son.
And I grab this little branch
behind me, tree,
and I get behind it.
And it's, like, this cherry bush
about as thick as my pinkie.
I'm like, "This is not
going to save me at all."
And I squared off
and just tried to go as Yoda
as I could with this ram
and just say,
"Not me, whatever it is."
He was kicking dirt
and everything.
He hops off the ledge,
swings back around.
We look over on the other side.
His harem is on the other side.
So we were between him
and all of his ladies,
and he didn't want any other
male scent on his mountain.
-Wow.
-And I was like,
"Your mountain, sir."
-See? I knew it.
I knew it was true, because --.
-I should have believed it.
-Yeah.
Well, I just --
We have just similar lives.
-Straight out of Brooklyn!
-Here we go. My turn.
Which envelope should I open?
Uh, number one or number two?
-Oh, yeah, that one. Two.
-You sure?
-That's the one.
-This could be the truth
or could be...
-A lie.
-...a lie. [ Laughs ]
"I once was attacked
by a ram on..."
[ Laughter ]
No, seriously. Here we go.
-It was related to the ram.
-Related to the other ram.
Yeah, we were on
vacation together.
[ Laughs ]
I was dressed as a baby.
Yeah, it was a Dodge Ram
that had me
cornered in my Airstream.
I was like, "Help!"
All right. Here we go.
"I, Jimmy Fallon, once docked
a ferry full of tourists
coming back from
the Statue of Liberty."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah?
What year was this?
-Yeah, when was this?
-I'd say 2000 maybe?
-Did you have a driver's
license back then?
-I do not drive a boat
or anything. No.
I had my driver's license, sure.
-Ohh.
-And what were you doing coming
from the Statue of Liberty?
-I love the Statue of Liberty.
I go there all the time.
-Just a Saturday, moseying
around, something to do?
-I don't think --
I think it was a weekday.
-Were you getting paid
for this job?
-No. No. I just like
the Statue of Liberty.
-As the ferryman, or were you
like, "Hey, I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Hey, Captain, let me dock
the ferry boat."
-No. I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't put
people's lives in jeopardy.
-Who went to the
Statue of Liberty with you?
-I went solo.
I went by myself.
-What?!
-Oh, it wasn't -- You didn't
have a bunch of tourists
that came to see
the Statue of Liberty?
-There was
a bunch of people on --
-So because you took
the ferry solo by yourself,
a lot of people that really have
never seen the Statue of Liberty
had to sit over on land and
wait for you, as a celebrity,
to get back.
-No, I didn't go on the boat
by myself, the ferry.
I went with other people,
but I didn't invite anyone.
It wasn't like --
I went by myself.
-There were a lot of seats
still open
that people were waiting for.
-No, no, that's not true.
[ Buzzer ]
-Okay. So we can't ask you
any more questions.
-This is a lead-pipe cinch.
-I don't know, man.
I'm going to say it's a lie.
[ Drum roll ]
-You're going to say it's a lie?
-Both: It's a lie.
-It's true.
-What?!
I drove and docked the ferry.
It was the weirdest thing --
It was the weirdest thing ever.
That is what happened to me.
It was weird. I was coming back.
I went because I really --
I'm into the Statue of Liberty.
It's really amazing.
So I went.
I was just hanging out.
I go, "This is awesome."
Then I get on this ferry back.
And this captain goes --
People started getting
autographs and stuff like that,
'cause it was before, like,
cellphones really.
And so they wanted
autographs and stuff.
And the captain's like, "Just
come up here in the cockpit
and just -- you know,
so you won't get mobbed."
And I go, "Okay."
Then he goes,
"You ever dock a ferry?"
I go, "What are you
talking about?"
There's like probably
200 people on this thing.
I don't know how many
people fit in a ferry.
I didn't even know
what I was on.
Again, the guy was a great guy.
He's probably fired by now.
-No, yeah, he's not a great guy.
-He's not a great guy.
He's like, "Dude, turn the thing
and pull the throttle
this way and that way."
And I was like,
"What's going on?"
And I full-on docked the ferry.
It was absolutely crazy
and totally true.
And I was like,
"What just happened?"
That's what happens
when you hang out
at the Statue of Liberty.
-Solo.
-Yeah, here we go.
Solo. All right.
Tariq, here we go.
-All right. Which one?
Which one do I open?
-I think number --.
Number one.
-Uno.
-Okay.
-I can break you. I can know
if you're telling the truth.
I hang with him all the time.
Oh, he had it
the backwards way, yeah.
-"I once drove around with Kanye
West in the trunk of my car."
[ Laughter ]
-Kanye was in the trunk?
Yeah.
-And you were driving?
-Yes.
-Just the two of you?
-No.
-Who else was in the car?
-Uh, Common.
-You and Common.
And Common's riding shotgun.
-Kanye West was in
the trunk of your car?
-Yeah.
-And why did he end up
in the trunk of your car?
-He was avoiding people
who were trying to
take photographs of him.
-Oh, he should have gone up and
driven -- docked the ferry.
-I know. Right?
-But why didn't he go down --
Why didn't you put a blanket
over him in the backseat
or something?
-Um, yeah, I don't know.
I guess I -- I don't know.
-Whose idea was it
to go in the trunk?
-It was his.
-It was his?
"Let me get some privacy
in the trunk."
-I mean, he just wanted me
to get him out of there.
We were in a sneaker store
in L.A.
It's called -- I don't know.
I'm not going to mention it.
But --
-That one.
-It's a pretty popular,
you know, sneaker store.
You get the exclusive --
-Beep, beep!
-No. Get out of here.
There was an event there.
The store happened to be
about a block and a half away
from a residence
where Common lived.
He lived with the legendary
producer J Dilla there.
-Don't try to distract.
-I'm serious!
-The details are good here.
But from the sneaker store
to the trunk.
I'm sorry.
Do we go through the mall?
-No, we went out the back door.
-And got in the trunk.
-And he got in the trunk.
I drove.
-So far, it's been true, true.
-The living with --
The side story of
Common living with the
producer is nice, nice detail.
-I don't think Kanye
would be -- jump in a trunk.
It's not his -- I would say
Kanye would be like,
"Bring it, bring it."
-I hope it's true.
-Maybe today he would,
but this wasn't today.
This was a while ago.
[ Drum roll ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, look,
the storytelling alone --
Got to say the details --
throwing the scent off
on the side
like Bob Dylan would do.
I'm going say it's good enough
to say it's true.
And if it ain't, it ought to be.
-Kanye West was in
the trunk of your car,
and you drove him around --
You drove him, and he was
in the trunk of your car.
-Yes, a 2004 Porsche Cayenne.
-Ooh, the details!
-I don't even know what
that means. A small trunk?
-Common lived a block away.
-Is that a small trunk?
-With the producer.
-Yeah. J Dilla.
-J Dilla, who Common lived with
and was at a sneaker event.
Kanye likes sneakers.
Doesn't he have Yeezys?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Probably this is pre-Yeezy.
-Yeah, it's pre-Yeezy. He
probably thought about the idea
when he was locked in the trunk.
He's like, "I got an idea!
Get me out!"
-Right.
-Oh, man.
I like to be right
on these games.
Uh, no. No way Kanye West
would ever be in the back
of your trunk ever.
-I say he did.
-It's a lie!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ohh!
-That was a good one!
-My favorite, my favorite.
And Common lived a block away
with the producer J Dilla.
-J Dilla. That was the one.
My thanks to Matthew McConaughey
and Tariq Trotter!